i'm joined by chief danny smyth who will
be able to provide an update on winnipeg
police service operations
i'm also joined by jay shaw manager of
the city of winnipeg's emergency
operations center who will provide an
update on other city service impacts
i can advise you that i spoke with
premier heather steffensen earlier today
we discussed the need for com and for us
to ensure the lines of communication are
open between our governments
our city's senior officials have been
and continue to work with their
provincial counterparts to monitor the
situation and the impacts to government
services
i've spoken recently with ottawa's mayor
jim watson to express
my support for his efforts on the ground
in our nation's capital
i'm sure the residents of ottawa
appreciate mayor watson's leadership in
speaking out on their behalf as do i
finally i've also spoken with our police
board chair counselor marcus chambers
who like winnipeggers is monitoring the
situation as it unfolds
i want to thank our public service for
their ongoing efforts on behalf of the
residents of winnipeg by way of an
update traffic has been impacted in our
downtown
so if you have to be in the area i'd
encourage you to please monitor the
city's transportation management center
on social media
our officials in the transportation
management center are providing updates
for commuters
the city is monitoring the situation
closely especially for the maintenance
of access for emergency services
i've seen some reports of temporary
business disruptions that's not
something we want to see in the longer
term
businesses have been hit particularly
hard during the pandemic
we don't want to see additional and
prolonged disruptions for our local
businesses
it's important to note this is not the
first protest in our city during the
pandemic
as a community we respect the right of
canadians to protest peacefully and
lawfully
in doing so there is a recognition that
there may be temporary disruptions to
certain city services and operations and
to our residents
i'll now hand things over to chief of
police danny smythe for an update from a
police perspective followed by jay shaw
manager of the city of winnipeg's
emergency operations center for an
update on the impacts to city services
over to you chief smythe
then i was in charge of that yes uh
thank you uh thank you mayor bowman uh
the protest organizers have been working
cooperatively with the police uh on this
uh on this event
i can tell you that uh as of about a
half an hour ago there were about uh
between 50 and 70 vehicles in and around
broadway and memorial boulevard it's a
mix of
semi
semi trucks
passenger vehicles and i understand a
couple of uh
farm type tractors
we've experienced no real problems right
now we still have traffic
moving on broadway and on new york
going east and west we have allowed the
protesters to utilize memorial boulevard
boulevard to to stage to some degree
from broadway to york uh at this time
the uh
the organizers have been quite
cooperative with the police uh and we
are coexisting there and they are
facilitating their protest peacefully at
this point i don't have anything more to
add
at this time so i'll turn it over to jay
thank you chief
uh good afternoon i'm jay shaw and the
assistant chief of emergency management
for the city of winnipeg at this point
we are pleased to report that there have
been very few impacts to city services
what a big transit has had to reroute
some of its roots
in the affected area
near the legislative buildings and is
expected some delays during the
afternoon rush hour
we advise transit users to check their
schedules before riding
as the mayor and police chief of
mentioned traffic in the area around the
legislative is moving and flowing
but still flowing slowly is so if
possible please avoid the area
however if you do need to travel in the
area please be patient and finally i can
advise that we are not seeing any
impacts at this time on responses for
emergency vehicles
such as fire apparatus or ambulances
thank you and we'll turn it back over
for questions
first we'll go to sam samson from cbc
hello everyone good afternoon thanks for
doing this um
mayor bowman you mentioned you know
impacts to businesses in the area it's
not something you want to see in the
long run
what do you
what do you mean like about that what
are you concerned about that you felt
that you had to say that today
well i don't think anyone wants to see
what has
happened in ottawa
we have had
we always have had protests in our city
that
often will will cause
temporary disruptions to to traffic
you know we've i've certainly seen those
over my terms of office to date
and i think we need to recognize that
city officials provincial officials are
doing their best to uh
to ensure the the safety of everyone
while respecting the right of folks to
peacefully and and lawfully protest
i think what we just don't want to see
is is prolonged disruptions to our
residents who live downtown uh local
businesses that have been uh temporarily
affected and so uh hopefully the the
disruptions will be uh minimal and and
short-lived
thank you for that i guess this next
question is for anyone who can answer
then what's the threshold uh as we've
seen in ottawa it's gone on the protest
there has gone on for days so at what
point does perhaps law enforcement or
the city step in to
prevent disruptions to not only people
who work in the area and have businesses
but who live in the area
i can i can maybe start um so
they're
you know provided there it's it's always
of course
respecting the rights of folks to to
respect plea
uh or i should say to p peacefully
protest
um you know we we see that um you know
all over canada from time to time and
that's part of being in a free and
democratic society it's of course where
there's prolonged disruptions to
the rights that our residents have to
to obviously
exercise their mobility rights and other
rights to live their lives and so we we
we aren't seeing that at this stage and
so
um you know i think it's important to
note that you know the conditions on the
ground in respective communities will be
will be that uh they'll be unique to
their communities and at this stage you
know there's been some temporary
disruptions but
they have not been significant to date
and hopefully that's that's what we see
going forward
danielle from winnipeg free press
thanks um my questions are for chief
smythe
uh so you said the police service is
working cooperatively with the
organizers how long have they told you
that they intend to
be in the vicinity or or do the kind of
intermittent
blockade
i don't have any uh uh
information on what the intent of the
organizers is
in terms of the length of time they plan
on staying
what is the
service preparing for how long are you
preparing to respond to um
the protest and can you describe the
resources and the allocations that are
are required
so we'll work with the organizers as
long as we need to uh
at the present time the resources being
required to manage this event are modest
james from the winnipeg sun
good afternoon everyone just a quick
question for chief smith and a question
for the mayor
just wondering if there are any
plainclothes officers on site today
so typically an operational question
like that that involves tactics i
wouldn't respond to
and i won't pay either
fair enough uh mr mayor i'm just
wondering uh you know being out uh
watching the protest this morning seems
like a lot of desperation just wondering
is there any sympathy for some of these
folks who feel that they've you know
reached the limit
um look i think the there's no doubt the
uh pandemic has been difficult
for all canadians
uh most notably those that have had
their health impacted or have lost loved
ones
also those that are
caring for our residents in our
hospitals and so
i you know obviously we want to see
a demonstration of patience and kindness
with each other right now
um you know i think the the message of
freedom is one that has been answered
people do have the freedom to get their
vaccine or not there are consequences of
course with that most notably
to one's health
and so um
you know
again the ability for people to
peacefully protest is one that
canadians have the right to expect
where it starts infringing on other
canadians rights that's where
you know we'll obviously have issues but
at this stage
um you know based on the updates that we
have at this hour
the disruptions have been
you know not significant
thank you devon from ctv
uh good afternoon first question here
for mayor bowman uh we were seeing some
employees in city of winnipeg trucks
that were appearing to show support for
those at the protest uh just what do you
think of that happening
uh you know what i i haven't received
that information so um it's something we
can certainly look into if you can
provide more information to us we can
always look into that
but i'm
i'm not pr i that is not something that
i'm i'm aware of so i'm not able to
provide you with immediate comment
okay and a second question here for
chief smythe um
you said you don't know exactly how long
this protest is going to be or if it's
going to be continuing for more than
today but um if this does go into the
evening
will the horns be stopping tonight uh
once it reached that certain hour
you know i i can't speculate on what's
going to happen in the future the
organizers have been
pretty open with our members on the
ground and pretty cooperative
we'll just play it as it comes
mark from city tv
thanks for being available everyone um i
guess maybe this would be to
either the mayor or chief danny smythe
if organizers have been in contact with
you have they made any direct demands in
terms of what they would want for this
protest action to end in winnipeg
uh from my go ahead yeah i mean
i i'm not i haven't had any direct
contact with them so i'm not able to
answer that question so i'll turn it
over to you chief
and in terms of our uh
interaction with we're just there to
make sure that people are able to
demonstrate peacefully and that the
disruptions are minimized as much as
possible uh they haven't shared any
demands with us
okay thank you um
i guess mayor i'd be curious in your own
opinion in your feelings does a protest
like this do anything to you know impact
how you may view current public health
measures or vaccine mandates do you
think it will be effective in changing
some of the pre-existing stances on the
culvert 19 health and safety protocol
short answer is no
i think the
protesters are making their views clear
and they're entitled to do so
it's my hope and expectation that all
levels of government will guide
decisions around
vaccines and
other covid
public health measures based on the best
advice from health care professionals
that are grounded in science and and
fact and so
you know i think that that's where the
those decisions should be should be made
and i'll continue to support decisions
that are made on the basis of the advice
from health care professionals that
being said uh canadians
will have
and do have the ability and the right to
share their views on what they think of
those measures but it's my hope and
expectation that all levels of
government will continue to support
and be guided going forward based on the
the best advice from healthcare
professionals
brittany from global
good afternoon gentlemen thanks so much
for uh taking the time this afternoon
mayor bowman i just wanted to get your
thoughts on on what you've seen so far
from the protest and maybe chief smite
as well um you know the difference in
what you're seeing or are you seeing one
what we're seeing here in winnipeg
compared to what we're seeing in
protests in other cities and how you're
feeling about that so far
well i'm appreciative of the work that's
being undertaken by
our public service including the
winnipeg police service i'm appreciative
of the work
that's going on
with other levels of government
including the provincial government
you know
we'll have to see how
you know how things unfold
but at this stage
based on the information we have it's
been
peaceful and
and that's what we want to continue to
see
and we want to see the least impact on
the ability for our residents to go
about their daily lives and so
you know hopefully that will uh that's
that that will be the path forward
thank you and i guess um i don't know if
this is maybe for you or maybe for chief
smith there's been concerns in ottawa
that police and and the city there let
things get too far and are getting a bit
out of control what kind of contingency
plans are in place here if this
continues to go forward past just this
one day
is that for me
sure
i i guess first i would say that
every protest and every location is
unique in its own right
uh and it's
probably not fair to be comparing us to
ottawa at the moment
we have an open dialogue going with the
organizers that are here
on the ground locally
they have been
very open with us and and to date uh and
we're only into it
by six hours or so a very cooperative
with us so
um
you know i i don't think it's a fair
comparison looking at ottawa
anne from radio canada
hi
um my question is for advancement um i
know i'm sorry for mr bullman but as
well there could be as well for two
um
since you've met with the mayor of the
city of odawa uh what have you been
discussed what have you discussed about
and
was that
concerning
a plan to prevent what is happening
right now in ottawa
um so
i speak regularly with mayors across the
country
you know these kinds of protests are
happening in
in other locations as well
my primary reason for connecting with
with mayor watson was to just offer
support
and also to
just see how he was doing it's obviously
not a
uh not an ideal situation right now in
in ottawa
um you know
one of the things we just discussed is
you know the the fact that people have
the the lawful right to protest but it's
uh it's a challenge when uh those
uh those uh protests uh begin
uh in a in a lengthy way uh adversely
affecting local businesses and so we
just talked about that
again wanted to just offer my support to
him i know it's it's not an easy
situation right now and appreciative of
the work of the public service
in ottawa and the capital region
respective
agencies i know are doing their best
thank you and for now they have an
estimate of the number of people that
have participated in the manufa the
protest today and the people that will
come during the next day probably
i'm sorry were you asking for an
estimate of what's going on at the
moment an estimate of the number of
people you've said a number of trucks
but do you have an estimated number of
people
yeah we we estimate between 50 and 70
uh vehicles that are down on the site
right now i'm not sure what that equates
to in terms of people most of the people
are are in their vehicles from my
understanding
so it's been very manageable at the
moment the biggest preventative thing
that we have going for us is an ongoing
dialogue with the organizers so that
everybody understands
their rights and
and what the expectations are
thank you
sam from cbc did you have any final
questions
i do yes
uh this is for chief smythe um the
winnipeg city council put out a joint
statement condemning the use of um
racist symbols and comments during the
protests not only here in manitoba but
across
canada and i'm wondering if you'd like
to offer comment on the winnipeg police
services point of view on the use of
those images during these protests
yeah
i would share in
in that position uh i don't think
equating what's going on here with
symbols of oppression and nazism is
appropriate and and i share that
sentiment
okay thank you and the other question i
have i saw the police service tweeted um
that protesters got everybody to sign a
code of conduct um to participate in it
do you have any information on what's in
that code of conduct was that shared
with police
i i was aware that they had set up a
code of conduct amongst themselves i've
not seen it myself but
i was certainly informed of it so
um i i don't know what specifically is
in the code of conduct but again
my understanding is it's their
ability to demonstrate to us that
they're there uh peacefully
uh and just my other question um
i know it seems like a basic question
but what does it mean for protesters to
cooperate with police i like many people
may not have even participated in
protests before they might not
understand what that looks like so from
your point of view
what does cooperating
mean and look like
so typically when we become aware of any
kind of demonstration or protest
generally speaking we'll we'll reach out
to the organizers so that they
understand what you know their
constitutional rights are around
protesting but also an understanding of
how we can assist them in keeping safe
often protests take place
in public spaces and on public roadways
so we want to assist organizers so that
they can demonstrate in a way that
doesn't jeopardize their own safety or
the safety of other people so that's
first and foremost uh
generally speaking we reach out to offer
our assistance so that people
can
can protest as is their right
in a safe and peaceful manner and if
there's anything that we can do
to facilitate that we will
conversely we want to make sure that
they understand that you know they they
can't break the law per se they you know
we don't want to see anything escalate
that would become
unsafe or unruly
danielle from the winnipeg free press
thanks
so this one is for chief smythe and for
jay shaw so what are your biggest
concerns
operationally if the demonstration
does go for an extended period of time
from my perspective it would be just the
disruption for the
people and the businesses operating in
the area
we recognize that in a democratic
society we put up with some disruption
for protests but it would be
uh it would be hard for the people that
live and work in that area
and i would just echo what uh what chief
smith is saying in terms of the the
impacts to residents and
uh possibly some uh you know when we
look at critical infrastructure in terms
of access to
uh for emergency services we just want
everyone to stay safe so
i think then i do have a couple more i
was just
wanting to confirm whether the wps have
received any complaints related to
the demonstration uh so far or if there
have been any reports of altercations
between folks
we have not
james from the winnipeg sun
james is left uh devin from ctv
uh just one more for chief smith here
just i know you've said that you're not
really sure how long
they could be around protesting but um
if they are around for the weekend what
are the plans uh moving forward for
saturday and sunday
it would be more of the same we would
keep an ongoing dialogue with the
organizers to ensure uh that everyone
uh proceeds safely and
you know that we minimize the
disruptions
uh as much as we can
that's everything thank you
brittany from global
i'm good thank you very much
anne from radio canada
no question thank you
uh i'll just check one more time sam uh
from cbc are you good no i have one more
question please um this is for mayor
bowman uh you mentioned you spoke with
premier stephenson earlier today you
said uh about the need for calm i'm just
wondering if you can elaborate on that
why
why that came up
i i think there's just a recognition
that um
the uh
the issues that are being discussed
right now in some of these protests are
very emotional and
i think what is important for our
residents to know
is that government officials are are
doing their best to respect the the
rights of of our residents
both those protesting and
you know and as well as winnipeggers
themselves who
um you know may not share um
the the views of those protesting um and
so
you know primarily i i want to just
ensure the lines of communication are
are open uh hopefully they're not needed
for a very long time
we do talk regularly and we'll talk as
needed throughout the weekend and into
next week
but i
i convey to her our appreciation for the
work that her officials are doing right
now in and around the legislature as
well as the work that's being undertaken
by the the city of winnipeg
personnel including um you know both jay
shaw and and chief smythe and and all of
their uh team members
um i think you know in terms of um
you know some of the
images that we saw in our community last
week which um you know our council has
unanimously condemned
what we're seeing in in ottawa
in terms of the prolonged nature and
some of the
pretty significant disruptions to
to
you know the ability for the city and
its residents to go about their
businesses
we just want to ensure that there is
there is calm right now
that we recognize the the lawful ability
for peaceful protest but also that those
temporary disruptions shouldn't be
prolonged and so
we'll obviously just keep those lines of
communication open
as they have in in recent weeks since
she became premier but certainly with
just
what we're seeing in in other cities um
i wanted to ensure the lines of
communication we're open with the
premier and um she's obviously in in
agreement with that
thank you okay no problem
danielle from the free press did you
have any more questions no good thank
you uh and last one devin from ctv did
you have any further questions
no i'm good thank you
all right i believe in that conclusion i
still have a question oh sorry mark okay
we'll go to you
thank you uh i just wanted to ask like
there's a very prominent and massive
american flag next to a canadian one do
you know if any of the protesters have
come from the united states to winnipeg
for this
i i certainly can't speak to that i i
would presume based on what we've heard
there's a number of non-winnipeggers
that are um that are at the the protest
um that's their their uh they have the
ability people have the the right to
travel and i can't explain why there's a
such a large american flag there but
again um you know people have the
ability to uh
to uh to have a flag of that nature and
i but i couldn't i couldn't speak to
where people's residency or citizenship
is
chief smythe any chance you would know
no i'm not aware of the origins of any
of the protesters
thank you
all right now i believe that concludes
our press conference thank you thank you
everyone uh thank you chief thank you
jay shaw uh have a great weekend
everybody merci maguitch